if it's okay you've mentioned uh alaka
mosque a couple of times I would love it
if you can describe why it is such an
important
place a holy place for Muslims in
general but also for this particular
crisis that we have been speaking about
today so Muslims honor the history of
all of the prophets right so all of the
prophets that have walked in that place
all the prophets that have worshiped in
that place all of that makes it sacred
right so it's not separated from Muslims
from uh you know post Muhammad peace be
upon Him versus prior to Muhammad peace
be upon him in terms of the sanctity of
that place so we honor it and uh M AA in
particular is the place where the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him leads
the other prophets in prayer in the
night of what's known as
the night journey of the Prophet peace
be upon him and then he ascends to the
heavens and back and it's also the first
which is the first uh place of direction
of prayer for us so before Muslims faced
Mecca in prayer for the first half of
Islam they actually faced towards
Jerusalem in their prayer it was our
direction of prayer and it remained a
fundamental part of our faith uh
fundamental holy Sanctuary there are
three sanctuaries in Islam Mecca Medina
and jerus
and M is precious to us and so you can
imagine then the pain of watching you
know innocent Palestinian worshippers
being stomped on by Israeli soldiers or
skunk water being sprayed on people as
they're trying to walk in or uh you know
tear gassing taking place in the nights
of Ramadan uh in that place the
restrictions on people that live right
next to it and that cannot pray in it uh
due to the certain class of ification of
Palestinian that they've been given or
the age right because uh generally
speaking if you're younger you're not
allowed to go to
m uh even if you live within the
occupied territories so it's it's tough
to watch such a sacred place with such
an ugly
occupation but I'll also say this that
the sanctity of a human being the
sanctity of just one person is greater
than the sanctity of any place of
worship to us so the sanctity of one
individual in Gaza or one individual in
Jerusalem is greater to us than the
sanctity of a place of worship but it is
all certainly
interconnected that's a really powerful
idea the value of a human
being is greater than even the AL of
mosque that that's a foundational idea
for Islam the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him uh says to the Caba
itself that the value
of a believer's dignity and honor is
greater than the value of the structure
itself and so when I
see a person in Gaza aggressed upon when
I see one when I see one child that's
greater to me than even ala but Al AA is
at the heart of who we are uh as well
and it's certainly at the heart of uh
the Palestinian cause it's a place of
Prophecy
and it's a place that should be treated
prophetically